[Musik]
ich bin banzer kommunalfahrzeug 935 in
groß mittel die aufgaben eines panzer
kommunalen science die gruppe zu führen
sowie den schützenpanzer ulan im gepäck
zu hören
ich sage meine fahrer wo er hinfahren
muss und erteile gegebenenfalls befehle
an gegen van drie was sie zu machen
haben ich bleibe am schützenplatz und
halte verbindung zu empfindlich
[Musik]
med
ich bin richtig schützenbahn zu land
gehören das bedienen der kanone das
bedienen der wartung der geräte und
unterstützendes genannten durch
erschießen ist das highlight von jedem
recht schützen kann man die verkauft vom
panzer zum sieg
[Musik]
nach dem absitzen der infanterie
unterstützen wir sie beim vorgehen und
bleiben im ständigen funkkontakt
ich bin ein trikot land im van-segment
135 die aufgaben eines infanterie
rekruten komponente sind eine gruppe zu
führen die aus sechs personen besteht
in verbindung mit einem schützenpanzer
[Musik]
wichtig dabei ist die verbindung zum
panzer
und die verbindung untereinander
[Musik]